european leaders arriving in brussels
for a crucial meeting on ukraine
at the start of the crisis they'd
surprised many with unity and strong
sanctions but a sixth package of
measures including a ban on oil from
russia had been stalled for nearly a
month because of objections from the eu
leader with the friendliest relations
with vladimir putin even at the start of
the meeting hungary's recently
re-elected prime minister victor orban
seemed opposed there is no agreement of
course the problem is you know that we
are in a very difficult situation
basically because of the irresponsible
behavior of the commission the head of
the commission didn't address such
criticism but she too suggested there
wouldn't be a breakthrough during this
meeting we are not there yet
but it has matured for sure
my expectations are low that it will be
solved in the next 48 hours as ever the
formal sessions at these summits are
closed to the public but president
zielenski's office released part of his
speech when he joined the meeting by
video link
finally all corals in europe must end
internal disputes that only encourage
russia to put more pressure on you
on the whole of europe
the sixth sanctions package must be
agreed
it must be effective including oil to
make russia feel the consequences of
what is doing to ukraine and the whole
of europe
it's not clear whether president
zielenski's intervention changed things
but there was a breakthrough soon
afterwards the final sanctions package
agreed but this is not the original oil
ban proposed by the european commission
it's been watered down it now covers
just russian oil that are shipped into
the eu not oil that is pumped in by
pipeline an important concession for a
landlocked country like hungary well
after midnight in brussels and the
european commission president along with
the president of the european council
were back to mark the fact that a deal
had finally been done thanks to this
council should now be able to finalize a
ban on almost 90 percent
of all russian oil imports by the end of
the year this is an important step
forward um the remaining 10
on these one we will soon return to the
issue
of these remaining 10 percent pipeline
oil the leaders here also know that
while this action punishes russia the
economic consequences will likely be
felt hard inside the eu too james bays
al jazeera brussels